President Trump is taking his border
wall campaign to South Texas
today after blowing up talks to end the
partial government shutdown by walking
out of the room the president had asked
congressional leaders for a commitment
to pay for a wall after the government
reopens the Democratic House Leader
Nancy Pelosi said no the president
tweeted that the meeting was quote a
total waste of time and said he told
Pelosi bye-bye nothing else works he
plans a series of events in McAllen
Texas this afternoon major Garrett is at
the border checkpoint in the nearby town
of Hidalgo major good morning good
morning president Trump wasn't
interested in making this trip I heard
him say it'd be a waste of time so did
other reporters that was at an
off-the-record lunch earlier this week
at the White House news organization is
reported about that the president's
tweeted about it so it's more or less
out there but the president also said is
what he meant is that this one trip was
unlikely to change anyone's mind that
both sides are entrenched and unable to
agree on the most basic set of facts
that was clear after yesterday's most
recent negotiating session the president
is traveling to Texas leaving a sea of
shutdown acrimony in his wake and we saw
a temper tantrum because he couldn't get
his way
Democratic leaders are unwilling to even
negotiate that behavior is embarrassing
to me it is unacceptable to put 800,000
people at risk he thinks maybe they
could just ask their father for more
money but they can't congressional
leaders offered conflicting accounts of
a meeting with the president aimed at
reopening the government that instead
descended into disarray when leader
Pelosi said she didn't agree with the
wall he just walked out and said we have
nothing to discuss she again to argue
whether we even have a crisis or whether
facts are true as federal workers feel
the pain of the shutdown Washington
Vickers about who was negotiating and
who isn't well the president walked into
the room passed out candy despite that
sweetener the talks remained sour and
after meeting with Republican senators
the president was asked by reporters if
the rank-and-file is standing by his
shutdown strategy
the White House has shifted its message
from shutdown enthusiasm I am proud
to shut down the government for border
security chuckle - exaggerated claims
about terrorist crossings at the
southern border nearly 4,000 known or
suspected terrorists come into our
country illegally
- emphasizing migrant suffering Manit
Aryan right not terrorists it's actually
both - considering declaring a national
emergency in order to sidestep Congress
and use pentagon funds for the wall I
have the absolute right to do national
emergency if I want my threshold will be
if I can't make a deal with people that
are unreasonable there is an emerging
theory in the White House that this
national emergency declaration might be
the best way might be the only way out
of the shutdown it would give the
president the money he wants for the
border wall allow him to sign the bills
to reopen the government yes there'd be
a political fallout and blowback legal
challenges but the White House theory
believes those are fights worth making
John so major if the President does go
that route and declares a national
emergency
what agency builds the wall Army Corps
of Engineers made up mostly of civilians
interestingly the Secretary of the army
and the chief engineer of the Army Corps
of Engineers coming with the president
here today about twenty billion dollars
in unspent pentagon funds available to
the president for this use so we might
be seeing that in the not-too-distant
future hmm all right thanks major